there's one thing we're doing next year
that really is the culmination of these
10 years and it's called Avengers
infinity war almost every single hero
that we've ever introduced is going to
be in that film why you ask
because of one person you got a glimpse
of them at the end of the first Avengers
film you saw a little bit more of them
in guarding to the galaxy and then you
saw them grab a golden gauntlet at the
end of age of Ultron
ladies and gentlemen Thanos Josh Brolin
[Applause]
you knew him first is Jarvis then his
vision Paul Bettany and Wanda Maximoff
the Scarlet Witch Elizabeth Olsen there
were a few Guardians became as well you
met her this year in volume 2 is Mathis
welcome Tom Clement EF the reluctant
daughter of Thanos nebula Karen Gillan
[Applause]
track dave bautista
ladies and gentlemen war machine Don
Cheadle
and the Winter Soldier Sebastian Stan
and the Falcon anthony mackie
[Applause]
dr. strange Benedict Cumberbatch
[Applause]
these guys have not been together on one
stage for a long time and even I find
myself geeking out honestly the only
thing that can make me geek out anymore
as if spider-man swung in here ladies
and gentlemen Tom Holland the king of
Wakanda black panther Chadwick Boseman
is this all we have know because we also
have a Hulk
ladies and gentlemen Mark Ruffalo the
mighty for Chris M blur I guess it's
worth bringing out the man who started
it all ladies and gentlemen Robert
Downey jr.
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh man should we take a picture guys
we'll take a picture come be swell up
here photo op
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well let's get your Rousseau out here
[Applause]
look at all these actors up here and
think about all the characters that they
play on all the stories that that Marvel
has told with these characters so in
order to celebrate that we have put
together a little look back at Marvel
that we want to show you just as a
celebration of this culmination of this
10-year journey great show we're gonna
watch the guys let's stay over here
thank you so much